disney and marvel want to show off some
new games next month so we're letting
you know what you can expect from that
showcase and more
disney's d23 expo kicks off in september
and this year there'll be a digital
showcase devoted to featuring new
content from upcoming disney and marvel
games hosted by kondo funnies blessing
adeyoye jr according to disney there
will be new reveals for disney dreamlike
valley marvel's midnight suns lego star
wars the skywalker saga as well as the
first look at sky dance media's new
marvel game described as a marvel
ensemble game the game was originally
confirmed in october of last year and
development is being led by uncharted
writer and director amy hennig beyond
the skydance project there's plenty of
other content on the horizon that
features disney and marvel properties
disney dreamlike valley might look like
it's inspired by animal crossing in
stardew valley but this slice of life
sim makes plenty of effort to
differentiate itself from other
properties i've gotten the chance to
play a couple hours of dream life valley
and i gotta admit i kind of love it but
i'm a sucker for disney pixar characters
and like town building and farm sim and
all of that stuff like right now at the
same time i'm playing bear and breakfast
two point campus and cult of the lamb
which all have like resource management
and building and
but i digress back to the story as for
marvel's midnight suns it has been
delayed to next year and the firaxis
developed tactical turn-based rpg will
now release before the end of take two's
fiscal year which concludes on march
2023 but what about games like marvel
spider-man 2 or marvel's wolverine or
even bethesda's indiana jones well the
announcement doesn't mention insomniac
or bethesda but it also doesn't say that
we shouldn't completely count them out
so here's my prediction we don't see
those games at this showcase at all
because jeff keeley is holding
spider-man hostage so we're either going
to see a new spider-man trailer
at gamescom opening night live or
at the game awards
i said it i said is it a wild prediction
maybe but i said it let me know your
predictions down in the comments below
and uh what you really want in
spider-man 2 or the wolverine game
switching gears to gentian impact
gention's version 3.0 update will go
live on august 24th the developer says
that this update will add new characters
and quests in the samiro region which
has expansive forest desert and city
sections the big gameplay edition will
be the dendro element the seventh and
final piece in genchin impact's
elemental system according to the
developer dendro can trigger burning
bloom and catalyze reactions when used
with pyro hydro or electro elements
respectively with more advanced
combinations also available as for the
sumero region the forest features plants
and creatures with dendro
characteristics and monsters can switch
between different states of attack
sequences on the fly but okay i already
gave you some homework for the comments
earlier in the video but let me know if
you're still playing gentian impact i
know it's still pretty popular but i've
kind of got like my eye on tower of
fantasy should i give that a shot i'm
gonna give it a shot i'll let you know
how it goes later this week that's my
homework i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
you